[Music]
this week on worlds stories drought hits
Kenya a country facing disaster hiv/aids
in Russia epidemic of denial but first
we visit Texas where there are barriers
along many parts of the US Mexican
border DW spoke to ranchers near
Brownsville about President Trump's
plans to build a wall the reaction was
mixed
[Music]
the border fence cuts through his land
no matter what rusty monsters ghosts
it's almost always inside Montez has
spent his life here on the border with
Mexico and all too often he watches
drugs and people were smuggled into the
u.s. monster says each year it has
gotten steadily worse that's why he
voted for Donald Trump and that's why
Monza's is for Trump's border wall until
Mexico cleans up its own government to
stop the and more of the illegal
activities we will need this wall
because the United States is a is a big
marketplace for illegal drugs for
illegal people two-thirds of his land
lies between the Rio Grande River which
forms a natural border to Mexico and the
border fence each day Montes travels
back and forth through one of the
transit points
Monza's suffers from cancer he says if
the government needs his lands to build
the new wall he's ready to sell actually
I love this property I was raised here
but I'm in a medical situation all the
stress and everything is not helping
what I've got just next door lifts
Pamela Taylor when the border fence was
built here ten years ago she found
herself living between the Rio Grande
and the fence effectively her home is
no-man's land
she knows every border guard here but in
spite of this she doesn't feel safe not
long ago drugs were found on her
property you have to be alert you have
to make sure that your doors are locked
you have to make sure that if you go out
your windows must be closed and
everything I mean there are so many
things that you have to do to make
yourself safe Pamela Taylor does not
want a border war between the u.s. and
Mexico
she says the old border fence has
achieved nothing Taylor wrote numerous
letters of complaint to lawmakers but
she no longer trusts politicians she has
a clear message for Donald Trump I
wanted to call him and I was going to
say you are doing exactly what our state
representatives did to us before their
bullying it in and we're going to build
a wall no no no you need to start
thinking about the people whose lives
you're going to disrupt before you start
building that wall
the 88 year old wants more patrols and
more border guards and if the government
needs her land for its new border wall
Pamela Taylor won't give up easily
because this she says it's her home
drought the animals are the first to die
then the children much of East Africa is
currently affected by arid conditions
unseen in decades Kenya has been hard
hit especially Turkana County in the
northwest Brown Creek water cattle
farmer caribou even yo walked half a day
to get here just to get something to
drink but there isn't enough water to go
around her grandchildren often go
thirsty food is also scarce many of the
family's cattle have already died people
here are surviving on a few wild beans
they've managed to find you don't want
much from any government we just need
food and water they should give us that
at least Caribous mother is weak she's
severely malnourished and in bad need of
medical attention but the medical
facilities in Tirana
are catastrophic most of the people in
the region belong to nomadic pastoral
tribes it's desperately underdeveloped
as a visit to a health clinic nearby
shows the door is open but there's no
doctor in sight antibiotics painkillers
and cough syrup lie on the floor and
open boxes it's disorganized and dirty a
man comes over to talk to us from a
school nearby
he says he's the mathematics teacher
there but he also works in the clinic he
tells us an aid organization constructed
the building and it's only recently been
open to the public he says he
understands a little bit about medicine
that makes him the doctor around here
you see even the register I do today and
up and up there is no there are he gave
me responsibility of looking here how to
hit calm yeah
it's unclear when exactly the doctor
will come by again Caribou opinion says
she doesn't rely on the Kenyan
government anyway the Turkana Nomad says
she just hopes it will rain soon
then the dried-out riverbeds behind her
hut will once again fill with water that
would save the last of her goats and her
family's livelihood 37 million people
worldwide are infected with HIV in
Russia the infection has reached the
middle class we speak with a woman who
talks openly about her illness
[Music]
three in the morning four at night
Auggie eremeyeva is 46 she's a
businesswoman and a grandmother she's
also HIV positive
Olga discovered her status by chance
after an accident put her husband in
hospital after surgery the doctor said
they couldn't figure out what was wrong
my husband had some virus at first I
thought it could be meningitis
it was HIV Olga and her husband had
lived with it for years undetected and
untreated within months her husband was
dead it couldn't be there was no way it
could be HIV that was always somewhere
else in someone else's life
I was always healthy always fit we cross
and Petersburg to the city's government
HIV center where Olga receives treatment
but how difficult is her case we read
you miss your witness engine we're now
seeing the epidemic entering the wider
population the kinds of patients were
seeing they're not drug users these are
people with families with children who
jacket or a medium you mean in most
cases they're being infected by sexual
transmission last years so reported HIV
infections in Russia topped 100,000 and
all-time high doctors estimate that the
true figure is significantly greater of
those patients that do know their status
only about 1/3 receive antiretroviral
drugs without them patients run the risk
of infecting their partners
Alden never considered keeping her HIV
status a secret it was never a question
for me I never thought about whether I
should be afraid of other people's
reactions when they heard about it for
me it's all about making sure the same
thing doesn't happen to other people
that's why she decided to tell her story
it's a timely message but one that the
official figures suggest isn't getting
through
our last report takes us to Berlin where
we meet Syrian Muhammed Ali Mohammed a
doctor of geography from Aleppo an
academic foundation in Germany has made
it possible for him to continue the
projects he was working on before being
forced to flee
[Music]
his world is geography
studying the changes in the Earth's
crust for two years the Syrian Mohamed
Ali Mohammed has been able to live and
work in Berlin financed by a fellowship
from the philips fonts initiative for
threatened researchers Muhammad taught
at the University of Aleppo until the
war in Syria put his life in jeopardy
once war broke out our apartment and all
of our possessions were destroyed and I
fled with my family and my parents to a
village on the border with Turkey from
there I regularly went to my work at the
University of Aleppo but there was
always the danger of being killed by an
air raid or by street fighting in the
winter of 2015 Mohammad was able to flee
across the border to Turkey from there
he contacted his former doctoral
supervisor in Berlin he had received his
PhD in Germany in 2010 but then he
returned to Syria they stayed in touch
I believe we have the advantage when
applying for the fellowship of having
long term personal academic and research
contacts dr. Adnan and the entire
faculty worked together on it the
philips fonts initiative supports some
70 scientists like mohammed throughout
germany it's founded in part by a
foreign ministry funding but also from
private donors the researchers come from
Syria Turkey Yemen and Sudan there's no
room for science mid war unrest and
persecution scientific work is
structured thinking and for that a
person needs faces of creative peace
which don't exist during times of war I
believe that it cannot exist in the face
of an immediate threat of war Megane
muhammad may be safe here in germany but
his family is not even though two of his
children were born here during his first
stay in Berlin my new
my family is now living in a refugee
camp directly on the syrian-turkish
border here in this corner that's the
border I hope that my family can come to
me here in Germany boostin but now
there's the problem that this border is
closed off by the military and at the
moment there is no solution yes
Mohamed would return to Syria but at the
moment he has no hope for a peaceful
future in his homeland all he wants is
to bring his family to safety here in
Germany
[Music]
you